this time on Bandit Patrol come on buddy
a reluctant swimmer needs some liquid
courage this boy is just not getting it
a baby skunk gives the team the slip the
chances of this little guy survive it if
I don't hide him is none there's
something wrong with his foot a downed
Hawk may never get back on his feet damn
that's disgusting I'm like seriously and
a tiny newborn's life oh he's so cold
hangs in the balance I need to make sure
he can survive through the night
foreign
[Music]
but lazy and hazy for wildlife rehabbers
good job if there's an animal in need it
doesn't matter what it is I
can no longer take summer vacations but
I'm telling you I do it because I love
these animals and it's all worth it see
you later
Kristen Allen's latest rescue is an
irresistibly soft orphan all right hey
guys are your cuteness overload you
ready
oh
you adorable do you know what he is
a mink that's right minks are fairly
common in Kentucky but because they're
nocturnal and pretty reclusive people
don't see them very often
this is the first baby mink that we have
ever had in our care so this is exciting
for the Allen Family his mom was killed
but the farmer was able to save this
little guy and she's named him Otis
she's had him since his eyes were closed
so like he knows nothing but humans I
truly believe that rehabilitating
animals is my purpose in life this is
what I was made for you look into those
big brown eyes and of course I say I'm
gonna go the extra mile to help you
so yeah you wanna hold her yes I really
do so yeah I well he likes you
Otis is way too comfortable with humans
you see this cute little face and like
you just want to snuggle it but you know
that you cannot love on this animal you
cannot humanize this animal your job is
to raise this animal so he could be
released back in the wild again
Otis has never seen another mink now at
two months old he may have already
imprinted on humans and runs the risk of
not being released we have to wean him
off people and get him into his natural
environment
all right one more they are semi-aquatic
so I really really want to see what he
does when we put him in the water
mink live on land but hunt for most of
their prey in rivers and lakes go ahead
try you can just put it in
okay oh I'm scared of water yeah it's
okay okay I thought he would just dive
in there and go oh yeah this is what I
was born for no not at all
[Applause]
okay this is not a good sign
we really have an uphill battle you know
what let me grab something he's got to
get in the water and he's got to like it
I actually bought this for you guys for
the pool but
um
oh it's like his little island Oh see
it's not so bad
he says yes it is
[Music]
you're doing better
there you go it's kind of like your kids
when you teach them how to jump in the
swimming pool they're always hesitant at
first and then they're like again again
and that's exactly what Otis was doing
this is much better although Otis is
seemingly healthy he's got a huge
learning curve here so after today it's
hands off if Otis stays too comfortable
with people he may never know that he is
a mink or how to be a mink
[Music]
the heat is on for rehabber Nikki
Christian and her daughter JC when skunk
babies are suddenly orphaned
especially love helping animals that
most people wouldn't help like these
skunks all animals deserve a chance
my name is Nikki how are you I'm
Michelle it's nice to meet you nice to
meet you too so tell me what kind of
surprise you've got there were four baby
skunks that were roaming around the barn
not seeing the mom at all okay sure
she's still here this is not good I
don't know how long they've been alone
they could have not had water or food
for days
playing this outside area around the
barn they're right there
these skunks are about five to six weeks
old at this size almost anything could
take them as prey even a house cat could
actually kill them
these skunks would have lived with their
mom for another six to seven weeks at
least they're too young to be on their
own you know they can spray at this age
oh they got their butts towards me it's
nice and slow JC Elizabeth
skunks can Target their spray up to 15
feet away
hello guys
I know I still poops
you better take your tail tucked no I
can't keep in touch with these gloves
okay
most people probably want to kill skunks
but they take care of a lot of insects
that we don't need they're one of the
best animals for our environment oh yeah
you didn't touch that tail at all did
you
that can smell
that's all right part of it
[Music]
honey there's three
there I just want to look one last time
we've looked all over outside cannot
find the fourth one
my biggest concern was that the mom has
been gone for a few days I don't want
one laying around and dying by itself
somewhere
the owner has seen him going at the barn
door so we're going to look inside the
barn
look at all kinds of places to hide
there is hay everywhere can you move
that Bell yeah you're gonna have to the
chances of this little guy surviving if
I don't find him is is none really he's
a little hole I don't want him going any
deeper
ah
there she is right there
all right I got it I got it
oh last but not least
JC I just want you to look one last time
and just make sure there's no more in
there
I don't see anything okay good they are
absolutely stinking cute stinking
very much
considering these babies were orphaned
they looked pretty good but it's gonna
be a long road
you can't learn without their mom
they'll never survive in the wild
[Music]
fellow rehabber Bridgette Williams has a
full house
but there's always room for an animal in
need
hello this is the second chances
Wildlife Center I found a baby bat does
it
have any fur
it has no shirt oh it is a baby that I
am happy to come get this little guy
I'll see you in a bit thanks
I love bats they are so misunderstood
when people find that I just humanely
offer compassion they deserve a chance
to live as well the minute I stop
wanting to help each life is the minute
that I should stop rehabbing
that pups are very fragile this little
guy he doesn't have fur he can't
maintain his own body temperature it's
up to Mom to help with that and in this
case it's going to be up to me
hi there
how are you oh gosh okay
oh
it's a hearing yeah poor little guy that
looks like a big brown okay it was just
laying outside on the deck when I woke
up this morning it looked down closer he
knows there's a baby back
This Bat pup is so tiny his skin is
see-through definitely a newborn I think
this baby has probably Fallen he's been
cold for a little while because he's
very cold to the touch so no other ones
around just this little single one no I
am always happy when people appreciate
the bat and try to help them so thank
you so much
a newborn bat pup away from their mom is
always at Great risk even though it's
still alive the body temperature is very
cold
right now my top priority is to get this
bat stable or he's going to die
first thing I'm going to do before I
even check this little baby bat is to
warm him up an incubator
the incubator is going to supply the
constant warmth that he needs
[Music]
I can tell he does not feel good I can
see it in his behavior
we can whale
in order to be viable he needs to be
about four grams the difference between
three and four grams is life and death
okay let's see
four grams
oh thank goodness
his stomach is so small he must be fed
every two hours
sure must be hungry
but I've taken it
my eyeballs almost can't even see
if you look really really close here you
can still see his umbilical cord on
I wish he had his mama
the pup is weak and vulnerable
I need to make sure he can survive
through the night
the next 24 hours are critical
he needs round-the-clock care
in case anybody is wondering why
I tried to save something so fragile
bats are so crucial to mosquito control
without bats there would be an explosion
of mosquitoes that potentially carry
viruses like zika and West Nile every
single bat makes a difference
for this guy to survive
it's going to take a miracle
hang in there buddy
[Music]
it's time for breakfast
after a long night of intensive care
Brigette checks in on the tiny bat pop
this little bat has survived of the
night I don't want to get my hopes up
too much but what I'm seeing today is so
much better here it is okay he is warm
and he is stable
[Music]
this feeding is much more enjoyable than
the 5am one that I did earlier
and I can already see that his belly is
getting big
[Music]
okay baby but now the bat pup faces a
new problem
because this little bat came in by
himself it's very important that I get
him with another bat and let him know
that he's a bat
this pup would have stayed with his
mother for his first eight weeks raised
by itself
a group of bats
see if I can take that and he does not
want to let go of this
it's like a baby with a pacifier
yep
this just happened
he's sound asleep he's pretty cute if I
don't find a little bat pup friend for
this guy there's a chance he might not
be releasable
let's get tucked back in
Otis the Mink's basic training begins
with a battle
is Froggy Friend or Foe he's just like
oh I'm gonna wrestle you the Allen
family loves this little guy
the Otis so we give him toys to provide
him that stimulation that he needs
[Music]
vicious this play is actually practice
for The Great Outdoors
minks are vicious
predators
scratch fish rodents they can take down
things way bigger than they are we don't
want to discourage those Natural
Instincts
Otis will have to apply these new skills
to real prey
suddenly there's a new Rescue that needs
Urgent Care
all right hey Mom
I'm really surprised that this bird is
still alive
this red-tailed hawk was found on
someone's lawn it's just been down for a
couple days
he seems young don't you think so
I love Raptors they're just so beautiful
so Majestic and so great for our
ecosystem
he's only got a couple of his red tail
feathers
they are he's all dirty because his
feathers are so rumpled Kristen names
him Einstein I guess speak somebody
let's check he's pretty thin I can't
believe he's not biting me red tail
hawks aren't this sweet
like he's not even going after you there
is he what are you doing
I just don't feel good grandma
and his left foot is swollen why is your
foot inflamed
I don't feel anything broken inside I
mean the scales are just peeling away
which is not good that looks like a
squirrel bite there
his foot's probably got infected look
how that Talon is turned under I wonder
if he can even move it I don't think I
don't think he can it looks terrible
federal law states that birds of prey
have to have two working feet or we have
to euthanize
the doctor couldn't
we have to do whatever we can to save
that foot Einstein will die
[Music]
you're going to help feed
grab them with your hands
[Music]
it's been two weeks since the orphan
skunks were rescued I'm glad we got all
of them I'm glad they're safe they've
lost precious guidance from their mom
we are doing the alarm test
these skunks they're old enough now the
moms start taking them out and they
would start searching for stuff like
this
they absolutely love worms bugs insects
we're just gonna barely cover them up
but let's do what they do
I've got to make sure that these skunks
and find their food source or they could
starve oh look they're shaking little
teeth
skunks pack a mean bite they have 34
teeth two more than humans
Don't Spray me
I'm telling you they are the biggest
hoofers why poof on the hand that feeds
you
all right guys breakfast is served
he's smelling it
pick it up eat it it's not gonna bite
you it's working except for the little
guy he's not really doing anything yet
we got a later show your little brother
how to do it show them what to do
oh little guy's in there good deal
that's right final
oh yeah they are digging finding those
worms they are amazing they just need a
little more practice and they'll be
ready to go
your mom would have been so proud
[Music]
Einstein the red-tailed hawk with the
swollen foot is rushed to the vet I'm
always hoping for that quick and easy
fix just make it better all right let's
go handsome
hey there Dr Lindsay how are you I'm
good all right
this is the guy Einstein
when you look at
the bossy there
how much was he using the foot
with both feet but never moves that
middle Tower
and I don't know if that owns like
totally rotted away but I'm not sure how
far back I kind of all got to deal with
so
it's not a healthy looking tissue you
know we're probably getting sedated so I
can just see what we've got left at that
point
Dr kunzi must assess the severity of
Einstein's infection sleeping time if we
can't save this foot his rehab ends
right here
let's go develop three three and two
keep a hold on they're going to try and
start just you know scab and the other
pus is just dried
that was disgusting yeah I'm like
seriously the end of a toe it's gone
there's no saving that
um let me protect the end of the toe
[Music]
Einstein can live with a missing toe but
amputation is risky
I am so relieved that he is keeping that
foot amputation of a toe always makes me
a little nervous millimeters really
matter but if we don't do anything he's
gonna die
just leave as much as much as we can
get your mom fixed up
Einstein's toe removal is serious
business
you don't remove enough the
life-threatening infection spreads
remove too much and Einstein can't hunt
land or defend himself
looks good
I think the amputation went well
we have him on a strong antibiotic to
prevent any further infection
we had to cut back about half of the toe
thank you
thank you very much my biggest concern
with Einstein right now is we need to
make sure that toe heals well
all right let's go buddy only time will
tell if the infection is all gone and if
Einstein can continue his rehab
[Music]
's tiny bat pup has been hanging around
for over a month and is now ready for a
new family
another bad pup was recently dropped off
and is a little older than the boy pup
yay we have two back hooks bats are very
very social and they are healthier if
they can be in with other bats
in about five weeks bats are weaned off
milk and onto solid food
this female bat is already eating whole
mealworms
she's a pro
she's a little
good job the boy bat must move on to
solid food and eat on his own or he
won't survive in the wild
are you waiting for me would you like to
try to eat a worm
you never know pinch the Worm for him
and barely dip it in the mix so it
tastes the same
oh
you're so exciting
I'm so proud of my baby
that is awesome I hear crunching
now that both of these baths are eating
on their own that is one step further
towards their independence this really
is a great step
chew it to it
uh he liked that
that's it lunch is over now these bats
face their highest hurdle flight school
I have to get you guys ready to fly
where are the scissors and stuff lovey
two weeks since Einstein's surgery and
his future depends on how well he's
healed so he's not real sweet just
remember that in the Cranky Pants come
here
we're gonna took his bandage off we're
gonna see how it looks and then we're
gonna take the stitches out
if the foot is infected it's the end of
the road for Einstein
we need to make sure that this infection
is under control because you cannot
amputate a foot on a bird of prey
this is where the toe was amputated Dr
Kinsey just removed just the tip of it
because he wanted him to have as much as
he can to balance on
yeah it's looking good isn't it
Einstein's toe looks exactly the way I
want it to look it has healed amazingly
there's no infection it's perfect kind
of like a pig leg yeah he's
he's got a nub there doesn't he
can get to these stitches
look at him oh he goes go ahead get your
hand close to me Kristen I'll take care
of that for you what happens if we leave
the stitch in well it's kind of like
when you get a splinter in your finger
and it just kind of festers the stitches
do the same thing
[Music]
[ __ ]
so
here I'm gonna try to I can't I can't
see that it's too small for me
oh Lord you're getting the Grammy
glasses on they're not granny glasses I
they I'm just gonna be able to see with
them better they're like a magnifying
glass for you
[Music]
I love having my girls with me when I
rehabilitate Wildlife I couldn't do it
without them
you're a lifesaver all right
I like helping my mom out because I love
animals and I think that every animal
should be helped
there you go Einstein you were a patient
patient bird
I spoke too soon
when Einstein is fully healed he'll head
to the Raptor Center to tackle his next
challenge
but now I'm worried that he's not going
to be able to balance or catch live prey
so this is the next hurdle that Einstein
has to jump over or fly over
we've got a long road ahead of us
you ready minky Otis The Mink has been
one of the Allen's favorite house guests
for over two months what do you think
he's gonna think of his new enclosure he
says well I'll tell you this if there's
fish in it I'm gonna like it
get in there oh
now he heads Outdoors to take a walk on
the wild side
we only interacted with Otis when we fed
him but now that he's bigger he's got to
learn to feed himself
here we are Otis if he can't catch live
prey he can't be released
do you put the minnows in okay
[Music]
radio just
come on buddy see you looking yes he's
like I don't know about this it seemed
pretty big I think Otis is thrilled but
he's also a little bit nervous that he's
like this is a whole new world
thank you there you go buddy
wait a minute there's water somewhere
here
maybe if you just put them on top of the
wall
how may I reach that
oh
I'm big you're gonna have to get in
there Odin
don't cheat
let me taught you how to fish he says I
taught myself
Otis would have seen his mother catching
fish I'm not getting in that pond and
catching a fish with my mouth so Otis is
gonna have to just figure this one out
on his own
this boy is just not getting it
you're gonna have to get in there Otis
he doesn't have a room for being outside
Otis has been dependent on humans for so
long that I don't even know if he has
the wild instincts to know how to catch
these fish oh he ducked his head in
gave you a little nudge
that's nice
mink have partially whipped feet which
will help Otis become an excellent
swimmer
look I'm going under the water now guys
aren't you proud Ah that's what I'm
really proud of did you get it
good job Otis he showed me exactly what
he could do and um it was awesome
awesome now he goes how do I get out
we might have to stack rocks in there so
for himself
oh wait let me just wait I can do this
it's amazing how the Natural Instincts
kick in
Otis is really an exceptional thing he's
learning everything of his own
it was a proud moment when I saw him
problem solve and get out of that pond
okay I'm going back in I like this okay
I'm gonna catch this one too he like did
a front flip to do it too but fishing is
only half the art of mink survival now
he needs to learn how to hunt on land
all right let's go girls
I'm gonna lay right here and eat my fish
in the wild but he's also going to eat
small mammals so we're gonna have to see
how good a hunter he really is
all right
babies my little pulvers the once
orphaned baby skunks are now all grown
up oh you were asleep and you didn't
even know what hit you
today I'm releasing these four skunks
they are strong they can eat on their
own they're aggressive and they are
ready to go two without getting sprayed
you're okay
now I'm gonna take these three out
so I said one more to catch
hi baby
[Music]
for his size there was a lot of pressure
in that bite and the little sucker would
not let go
if I wouldn't have had those gloves on I
think I would have lost the tip of my
finger
this just shows how Wild they are
because it wants nothing to do with me
at all and right now I don't want
nothing to do with him
[Music]
this little guy has everything he needs
to survive in the wild
I'm taking these skunks to a place on
our property they're going to have
plenty of acres to roam and food and
water
[Music]
come on
check it out
yep there you go awesome
come on everybody else just checking
things out
see you got your nice little safe spot
there this little platform that we
brought here and it's just a temporary
home for Denver right now
Tim's already in there hiding it worked
out great
[Music]
this is a success story
the ultimate goal in rehabbing is to get
the animals out in the wild where they
belong not just to survive but thrive
I know they're going to be happy to be
back out in nature
[Music]
Bridgette's bats are sporting new fur
and can maintain their body temperature
they're ready to camp out
this is always a really fun stage in the
process of rehabbing bats this is their
first opportunity to really have a
decent distance to fly
whether they will fly or not is another
story
sometimes bats can be pretty lazy in
captivity and just don't feel like
flying so it might take them a day or
two to actually fly around and utilize
the space I'm going to take this little
one and just hang him on the wall
see what he does
[Music]
[Music]
your Camille
[Music]
this fat was so tiny when he came in
smaller than a half dollar
his skin was so thin no fur just a
helpless little fat and now he just
looks like a little puffball of cute fur
if these bats don't start flying soon
they won't build the stamina they need
to survive in the wild
[Music]
hoping they'll take flight yay
looks like it's ladies first that's
awesome it's okay that's learning
experience
[Music]
that was the very first decent sized
flight for this little bat to take and
just like baby birds flopping around as
fledglings bats have to learn how to fly
as well I'm just gonna watch and see
what she does
[Music]
that was awesome
this is really cool I can't believe
everybody doesn't love bats
here she is flying a little bit sooner
than this little guy
the boy bat is on Deck I'm just seeing
if I can open up the wing if in the
stink I'll kind of take over here
up instead of on the ground
it got it they're brilliant
these bats need a few more weeks to
build endurance before they're ready for
the wild
First Flight I got
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Owensboro Einstein's toe has healed from
surgery all right Einstein you're gonna
see blue skies that you haven't seen in
a while and now he moves to the Raptor
Center to put the foot to the test
[Music]
putting him straight in the white fly
cage hopefully today Einstein will show
me that even with that missing toe he
can perch well and he can make his
Landings
all right it's a bird you ready
I know it's been a while since you've
flown but you don't forget how to do it
it's me
need a little more exercise I think I'm
going to give you a little toss I want
you to stick your Landing there okay
ready one two three
[Music]
The Landing part still needs a little
work
okay that's all right
you've been inside for a long time buddy
let me grab you and just put you up on a
perch
red tailed hawks
get up there
oh he's wobbly
oh this is this is not good when we
amputate they have a hard time getting
balance
Birds spend the majority of their life
perching not flying if he can't balance
he won't be able to perch let alone
catch live prey there is no way I'll be
able to release it Einstein must adapt
to life with one less toe
I'm never gonna give up on an animal I
will do whatever it takes however long
it takes to get Einstein back in the
wild again
[Music]
after a few days of diving into his wild
training Otis is a master fisherman it
took Otis a little while to get in the
water but once he did those Natural
Instincts took over and he starts hiding
the minnows under his den since minks
don't have a whole lot of body fat you
know they store that extra food in their
den and save it for a tasty treat later
but today
Otis has to hunt prey bigger than a
minnow
I'm going to go ahead and put three live
rats be in there guard the door for me
okay in the winter where that water's
cold minks stay on land and they're
going to eat a lot more rodents if Otis
can't catch more than just fish in the
winter
he'll starve
Otis I'm out we brought you dinner
where your dinner went it just hid a lot
of people think that it's cruel to feed
live prey but Otis is a carnivore he's
got to learn how to do this the survival
depends on it there's one hiding right
here that's good because he's got to
learn to find him like they're not just
going to be out there just sitting for
him
oh there he is
I'll just smell it look at his nose
going
look at him coming out
he can hear him
they have an amazing sense of hearing
foreign
[Music]
comes here he comes here he comes right
here right here
let's say good job Otis but I feel
really kind of bad
[Music]
it's too gross
Otis being able to search out a rat is a
huge milestone in his development he can
hear it he can smell it and he can catch
it he'll definitely need those Killer
Instincts out in the wild
taking live prey is key to survival for
all predators
[Music]
Kristen hopes this core Instinct will
help Einstein overcome his disability
just wait to see what I brought you
today
red-tailed Hawks use precise movement
balance and Agility when hunting ready
for lunch huh
if Einstein shows me with that missing
toe that he can perch well stick those
Landings and catch that live prey then
he's going to be good for the wild again
looks good doesn't it
all right bed they're all yours
come on you can do it
all right
he's grasping with that leg
he's totally using that foot
awesome
not only can he grasp the perch
but his foot can handle Landings firm
and fast
boy he has passed with flying colors and
now he can even take live prey which is
like the final thing this boy is ready
to go out the door
I knew you could do it
sign
all right it's your time to go summer
school is over for these bats
mosquitoes are biting me everywhere
boost their chances of survival Brigette
releases them at night when mosquitoes
are most active
who wants to go first
our two little bat pups get to go back
out into the wild to take their first
really really long flight
come on the small ones are a little guy
that had all the issues
love these little guys
okay well I'll let you go first
but the female bat can't resist the
sweet temptation of a bug-filled night
sky represent your other one's sneaking
out behind you I wondered if that was
gonna happen there she goes right here
right here
oh that's awesome
[Music]
oh
I didn't get to say goodbye
now it's your turn buddy
[Music]
sometimes bats just choose not to leave
because they become kind of lazy in
captivity if the bat stays he may not
have time to prepare for winter
hibernation good to go baby it's time to
go
good to go baby brigette's boy bat is
all grown up but hesitates to fly away
like the female bat his window for
freedom is closing fast some are ready
to spread their wings and fly sooner
than the others
it's okay to go
here he goes this bat is definitely the
smallest bat I have ever successfully
rehabbed
[Music]
it makes the mother so happy
[Music]
summer comes to an end so does little
mink otises stay with the Allens
Otis has made an incredible journey from
our hearts to his home
[Music]
primary and Sophia
I saw him peek his little head out
okay
my family loves all the animals we get
in but when we get the little Underdog
Inn that's got a huge uphill battle like
they tug on all of our heartstrings not
just mine but everyone in the family
give them a little look over
come here it's okay
[Music]
hey Otis you look good I love this
little cute white spots all over
there's a little snack in there for you
buddy
[Music]
I love when my whole family is there for
release because we've been through all
this together
it's always Bittersweet when we let
animals go
but we know that's why we do this
it's a pond Otis a big pond these are
downed logs so many places for him to
find a home down here it's going to be
awesome perfect for him
all right Sophia you want to help me
ready handsome
all right come on minky
okay here you go
[Music]
just wait until you get out here you
will be so excited
here cutie
we're ready
I'm gonna go over here he was so excited
to have something so big
choose the perfect place to enter the
water
sometimes it's hard to say goodbye
you're sad
it's fine Sophia
Sophia is okay
it's fine Sophia
Otis isn't where he's supposed to be
okay
Otis is probably one of my favorite
animals that we've ever had in our care
and now I will never get to see him
again but I'm very happy that he's back
out in the wild
you ready yeah okay let's go
[Music]
[Music]
I think he's ready yep it's been several
months since Einstein arrived at the
Allen House aren't you looking handsome
with some animals it takes them a little
bit longer to heal but unless they give
up I'm not giving up and it's finally
time for him to soar I like the way
you're grasping that Branch now you're
going to make this easy or hard it's
gonna make it hard so they always do
take the gloves on and he'll fly this
way I'll try to grab him yeah all right
I like my job better I know it's
definitely five is good yeah he does
right all right that wasn't bad no not
at all
he is just as good as the bird with all
his talents
this boy is ready to go today and it's
about time
in a bit of time with Einstein because
you know he was down he was thin that
toe was infected and we decided to
amputate the toe and we had to make sure
that he could perch well and catch live
prey
it's been a long haul for this boy
hey girls are you ready I think he's
good
[Music]
he says but I have your glove Kristen
I'm good
I'm so glad those Talons work
s he has his red tail feathers now he's
grown up with us I know you're a big
bird now
are you ready
I've been ready for a while I know
you're exactly right okay one
two three
Buddies
so
good
[Laughter]
do you see him yeah I see him
when you have a bird that's more of a
challenge you know it's even more
special when you get to release them
back out in the wild again
the challenges are a good thing because
the end is even sweeter
foreign
[Music]
[Music]